هجمات جديده في البحر الاحمر وواشنطن تؤكد
بان الحوثيين لن يتوقفوا فيما لندن تتوعد
بضرب اليمن وتل ابيب تصرح اذا وسع لبنان
الحرب فسيت لقى ضربات لن يتخيلها وكذلك
ايران الجيش العبري يعلن عجزه امام صواريخ
الفصائل حكومه حرب تلبيب تمنح الضوء
الاخضر لبدء المفاوضات ما هي علاقه
الاسلحه الصينيه بالمسلحين في القطاع
القواعد الامريكيه في مرمى العراقيين زعيم
كوريا الشماليه يتحضر لاطلاق اقمار عسكريه
جديده حرب البحار
تستعر حرب بارده في طريقها للاشتعال في
الشرق الاوسط هل تنقلب حرب الكلام الى
معارك عسكريه وبعد ان كان وزير الخارجيه
الايراني حسين امير عبد الله هيان قد صرح
في لقاء صحفي ان نتنياهو ارتكب الكثير من
الاخطاء حسب وكاله الطلبه الايرانيه اسم
عبد الله هيان اكد ايضا ان بلاده سترد
بقوه وبحزم على اي مغامره او اعتداء من
الكيان العبري مشيرا الى انه لا يمكن
اعتبار توقيف السفن العبريه بالبحر الاحمر
تهديدا بينما يسمح لتل ابيب بارتكاب جرائم
بالقطاع وكان نتنياهو قد قال في مؤتمر
صحفي اذا وسعت مقاومه لبنان الحرب فستتلقى
ضربات لن تتخيلها وكذلك ايران ها نحن
نتصفح المصدر
من جانب اخر رفض نتنياهو اتهامات جنوب
افريقيا لتل ابيب امام العدل الدوليه
بارتكاب اباده ضد الشعب الفلسطيني مؤكدا
مواصله حربهم الدفاعيه التي لا مثيل
لاخلاقها وفق تعبيره في البحر الاحمر قالت
هيئه عمليات التجاره البحريه البريطانيه
ان تقارير تفيد بوقوع هجوم على بعد 60
ميلا بحريا شمال غرب ميناء الحديده اليمني
وذكرت الهيئه ان سفينه ابلغت عن تعرضها
لهجوم بثلاثه زوارق وانه جرى تبادل اطلاق
نار دون وقوع اصابات اليكم
المصدر
ليخرج المتحدث باسم القوات اليمنيه العميد
يحيى سريع ويقول ان القوات الامريكيه
اعتدت على ثلاثه زوارق ما ادى الى مقتل
عشره من مقاتليهم مؤكدا ان واشنطن تتحمل
تابعات استهداف زوارقهم في البحر الاحمر
فيما قال القائد الاعلى للقوات البحريه
الامريكيه في الشرق الاوسط نائب الادمرال
براد كوبر ان الحوثيين في اليمن لا يظهرون
اي مؤشرات على انهاء هجماتهم على السفن
التجاريه في البحر الاحمر من جهتها كانت
صحيفه تايمز البريطانيه قالت ان بريطانيا
تستعد لشن هجمات على الحوثيين في البحر
الاحمر وذلك في عقاب ارتفاع وتيره الهجمات
التي ينفذونها ضد عده سفن على خلفيه الحرب
العبريه على القطاع مما يزيد من احتمال
تصاعد التوترات بشكل كبير في المنطقه
وذكرت الصحيفه في تقرير لها ان المخطط
الذي تعده لندن ستنضم له الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لاحقا وربما دول اوروبيه اخرى
لاطلاق وابل من الصواريخ ضد اهداف مخطط
لها مسبقا سواء في البحر او داخل اليمن
حيث يتمركز الحوثيون بالعوده الى معارك
القطاع قالت القناه الثان ع العبريه ان
الجيش العبر عثر على كميه كبيره من
الاسلحه الصينيه التي يستخدمها المسلحون
الفلسطينيون في القطاع هناك قال رئيس
الوزراء العبر نتنياهو ان الحرب في القطاع
ستستمر عده اشهر اضافيه مقرا بتعقيداتها
فيما ذكرت اذاعه الجيش العبري ان الجيش لا
يعتقد ان بمقدوره القضاء تماما على قدرات
اطلاق الصواريخ لدى الجماعات المسلحه
بالقطاع وقال تقرير لصحيفه التايمز اوف
اسرائيل ان الجيش حقق نجاحا في اقتلاع
قاذفات الصواريخ بعيده المدى لكن سيكون من
الاصعب ازاله خطر الصواريخ قصيره المدى
تماما عن التجمعات السكنيه في غلاف القطاع
وقالت الصحيفه ان ضابطا كبيرا اضاف حتى في
غضون عامين ربما سيظل سكان غلاف القطاع
يسمعون صفارات انذار للتحذير من الصواريخ
ل نضع المصدر امامكم ان الجيش لا يعتقد ان
بمقدوره القضاع تماما على قدرات اطلاق
الصواريخ لدى الجماعه المسلحه في قطاع غزه
لتكشف صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن تزيد الضغط
الداخلي على رئيس الوزراء العبري للاسراع
في انجاز صفقه اسرى مع الفصائل في القطاع
ووفق الصحيفه فان جناحا في القيادات
العبريه يدعم مساله اتمام صفقه تبادل
للاسرى في الوقت الراهن ثم الانتقال الى
مراحل مستقبليه بشان القطاع بينما كانت
تقارير اع لاميه عبريه قد افادت بان مجلس
الوزراء الحربي منح الموساد الضوء الاخضر
للمضي قدما في الاقتراح القطري بشان
المفاوضات مع الفصائل لاطلاق سراح الاسرى
العبريين من القطاع وبحسب تقرير نشرته
هيئه البث الرسميه كان فان الاقتراح يرتكز
على وقف اطلاق النار لمده اسابيع لقاء
اطلاق سراح عشرات الاسرى بعدما كانت
الفصائل اصرت بوقت سابق على وقف نهائي
لاطلاق النار قبل المضي قدوما باي صف
مشيرا الى ان الاتصالات متقدمه جدا وفقا
لمصادر عبريه لنعد الى الحدود اللبنانيه
حيث اعلنت مقاومه لبنان استهداف مواقع
عبريه بالاسلحه المناسبه وحققت عناصرها
اصابات مباشره في صفوف الجنود العبريين من
جهتها اعلنت المقاومه في العراق انها
استهدفت قاعده رميلان الامريكيه شمال شرقي
سوريا بمسيرات في وقت تحدثت مصادر صحفيه
عن هجوم بمسيرات ايضا على قاعدتي العمر و
كونيكو لننتقل الى كوريا الشماليه حيث
تعتزم بيونج يانج اطلاق ثلاثه اقمار
صناعيه اضافيه للتجسس عام
2024 لتعزيز قدراتها العسكريه حسب ما
افادت وكاله الانباء الكوريه الشماليه
الرسميه وفي وقت سابق افادت وكاله رايترز
بان كوريا الشماليه حذرت من ان التدخل
الامريكي في عمل اقمارها الصناعيه سيجبرها
على الرد وتحييد الاقمار الصناعيه
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]